The ways of the world often baffle me.
I sometimes wonder if I missed the memo
about the most basic things.
What are you supposed to make for dinner?
What do you talk about in an elevator?
Why do people cut in line?
How do you leave a dinner party
without being rude?
Or do you leave it all?
["Why are you still here?"]
(Laughter)
My tendency to see the world
like I'm from outer space
was a bit of a liability when I was a kid.
True story.
["What's a noogie?"]
(Laughter)
But it's been helpful in my career.
I'm a cartoonist.
When I first started making cartoons
for The New Yorker about a decade ago,
I kept my ideas light and quirky.
And please shout out
if you don't get any of them,
I'll explain.
(Laughter)
["The synchronized swim team quits"]
I didn't draw anything too personal.
["Unicorns do exist!"]
I mean, personal for someone.
I figured I was too specific,
too hard to relate to
and read, possibly, too female.
It took a breakup.
(Laughter)
["I know there would be a time
I could wear them
without destroying my feet."]
(Laughter)
It took a breakup to get me to start
drawing more autobiographically.
The pain I was feeling, although
objectively pretty run of the mill,
was impossible to ignore.
[Tunnel of love]
I knew that drying was my strongest
problem-solving tool.
So I decided to diagram
what I was going through.
[Tunnel of love.
Just kidding. Wall of death.]
(Laughter)
By making these drawings, I could see
how my ex and I had hurt each other.
And move on.
Onto other breakups.
["Again?" Pit of despair]
(Laughter)
Drawing from my own life
was a revelation to me,
not only because it helped me
understand myself better,
but because it made me see
for the first time
that people could relate to me.
Now that I had this amazing tool,
there were so many problems
I wanted to solve with it.
The problem of scheduling.
[Work | Family / Friends]
The problem of too many things
happening all at the same time.
[ "I'm having a birthday party!
"I'm visiting New York!"]
The problem, relatedly, of time.
[Childhood / now]
And finally, dating again.
(Laughter)
There's an endless amount
to say about dating.
(Laughter)
There are, of course, problems
that can't be summed up
in a single drawing.
For these problems,
you need many drawings.
One more complex problem
I have is with God.
I'm Jewish, so I'm talking
about the God of the Old Testament.
My problem with God
isn't actually a big problem.
It's just, I don't know,
it's stayed with me.
My problem with God
is that he's too confident.
(Laughter)
For me, creation is an act
of solving problems,
of figuring things out.
God already seems to have
everything figured out.
He strikes me as more
of a king than a creator.
And I'm not sure you can be both.
As an experiment,
I decided to remake the Book
of Genesis as a graphic novel.
My version of God is not confident.
And maybe not coincidentally,
she's a woman.
It surprised me how few changes
I needed to make to the original text,
which is sparse and ancient
and lends itself well to interpretation.
For example,
the Bible opens in this
mysterious, moody way
with God floating aimlessly on the face
of a dark, mysterious void.
In my version, I have her
floating this way
because she's feeling despondent
about her limitations as an artist.
She's made this messy, wet, mixed up
dark first drafts of the world,
and she just doesn't know
where to go from here.
My version of God doesn't know
exactly what she's doing,
but she draws a horizon line,
and things start to fall into place.
She banishes Adam and Eve
from the Garden of Eden,
not because they disobeyed her,
but because, by eating the apple
and becoming wise,
she feels they have outgrown
the world she created for them,
and she needs to let them go.
She scatters the builders
of the Tower of Babel,
not because she's threatened
by their power,
but because, like any introvert,
she needs her privacy.
(Laughter)
When she destroys the world
in the story of Noah,
it's not because she's
incensed with mankind,
but because she's incensed with herself.
She knows she could have done
a better job when she made us.
My adaptation of the Book of Genesis
is a creation story full
of false starts and absurdities.
But it's a creation story all the same.
One in which a self-conscious woman,
even though she worries
and makes mistakes,
is nonetheless a successful,
committed artist.
When I finished my book,
I did feel a new connection
to the God of the Torah
and a new sense of belonging
to my religion.
I also felt a new sense of belonging,
period.
It's lonely being someone
who has no idea how to act normal.
But it's profoundly less lonely
being that person
in a world created for her
by an equally awkward, self-conscious God.
These days,
when I worry that I won't know
what to make for dinner,
I remind myself that God
wouldn't know either.
(Laughter)
This picture is giving me anxiety.
It's like, literally, I drew it from life.
(Laughter)
This gives me the confidence
to embrace my cluelessness
and just wing it.
Thank you, thank you so much.
(Cheers and applause)